[Musica]
bene grazie a tutti ovviamente per la
curiosità di sostenere una lezione di
fisiologia dell'ibernazione a metà
pomeriggio i miei studenti non sarebbero
così bravi a fare quello che fate voi in
questo momento e parleremo di una
tematica di solito piuttosto
affascinante che in effetti scatena le
fantasie che è quella dell'ibernazione e
oggi ci concentreremo sulle possibilità
di applicare questa cosa ai viaggi
stellari spaziali stellari siamo un po
troppo avanti perché i viaggi spaziali
da un lato l'afflato dell'uomo di
esplorare e quello che ci ha portato
prima a conoscere come ha fatto il
nostro mondo poi in atmosfera poi sulla
luna e adesso abbiamo mire diciamo più
espansionistiche in questo senso e
quindi quando il cielo tramontando sole
tramonta il cielo compare un certo tipo
una certa voce contro di noi ci dice di
andare a vedere cosa c'è di là
chiaramente quando si parla di
ibernazione dei viaggi spaziali di milia
di solito sono ben attenti a non farsi
scappare la notizia ed è divertente
rapporto che avevo scienziato può avere
con diverse testate e radio televisioni
giornali sia inglese che americani e
tutti loro si concentrano molto su la
possibilità e quando questa cosa sarà
possibile come sarà possibile come viene
raccontata e oggi vediamo un po come
questa storia io fortunatamente faccio
parte di un gruppo di ricerca
dell'agenzia spaziale europea che è
dedicato esattamente a questo perché
l'agenzia spaziale europea dovrebbe
interessarsi al ibernazione questo tipo
di organizzazioni ogni qualche anno
compie una perlustrazione delle ricerche
che vengono fatte in diversi ambiti per
cercare di capire quale sarà quella
branca della scienza che fra dieci o
vent'anni permetterà di sviluppare le
tecnologie che serviranno in quel
momento quindi non per sviluppare
qualcosa adesso ma per iniziare a
pensare come sviluppare in futuro
nel 2004 l'agenzia spaziale europea
prese in esame i capitoli ibernazione e
decise che era troppo presto e alla
fantascienza dieci anni fa
fortunatamente dal 2005 in poi si sono
succedute una serie di scoperte
estremamente rilevanti nel settore e nel
2014 lesa ha deciso
era il momento di partire con questa
cosa e quindi io è una serie di colleghi
cerchiamo di capire come arrivare a
ibernare degli esseri umani
cosa vuol dire ibernare non fatevi
confondere da una facile associazione di
immagine che la lingua italiana
purtroppo suggerisce cioè non viene
congelato nessuno congelare qualcosa si
chiama crioconservazione ed è quello che
offrono per esempio alcune ditte negli
stati uniti in russia per cercare in un
futuro lontanissimo presumo forse di
essere eventualmente resuscitati e
curare una malattia ora incurabile
questo è un settore veramente ai margini
della scienza della ricerca e non è
quello di cui ci occupiamo quello di cui
ci occupiamo noi è la stessa attività
quelle ibernazione che lo scoiattolo
l'orso il ghiro fanno in un periodo di
scarsità di risorse quando si trovano in
difficoltà perché all'intero non gli dà
abbastanza cibo
iniziamo questo viaggio quindi nel tool
che toccheremo alcuni punti piuttosto
rapidamente purtroppo ma questo è un
argomento piuttosto vasto per capire
come e perché c'è interesse in questo
tema intanto ovviamente ibernazione ci
ricorda la fantascienza la fantascienza
sfrutta l'ibernazione per diversi motivi
drammaturgici e il primo che ci viene da
pensare quello di un viaggio
interplanetario interstellare gran parte
dei film ma anche con un viaggio nel
tempo qualcuno ricorderà magari
dormiglione di woody allen presente nel
quale una persona si berna sulla terra e
poi si sveglia dopo molti anni in un
mondo diverso
a volte dal parlare di queste cose a
tavola
molte persone sono volontarie per essere
ibernate pensando di vedere un mondo
migliore nel futuro
io mi chiedo sempre se magari il mondo
migliore non sia adesso è ibernando c
forse perderemo la parte più divertente
ma è un rischio che qualcuno disposto a
correre
queste sono per esempio quattro immagini
di famosi film di fantascienza mettete
prova la prova la vostra capacità di
identificare questi film possiamo poi
rivelarli facilmente alla fine cosa ci
dice invece la storia su nelle scorse
per nazione beh io non so loro tutor lo
dico in tutte le conferenze
non so chi sia stato il primo a parlare
di ibernazione
dall'uomo immagino aristotele perché è
più o meno tutto quello di cui parliamo
si trova in un testo di aristotele ma
non ne ho la prova quindi se ci fosse un
regista che un giorno all'altro possa
risolvere questo problema lo apprezzerei
quello che so io è che durante
l'invasione russa della russia da parte
della grande allarme di napoleone ci fu
la prima osservazione che qualcosa nel
freddo era positivo per l'essere umano e
napoleone era un grande e generale aveva
ovviamente un apparato logistico di
primo ordine e cosa succedeva cosa fa il
corpo sanitario dell'esercito cosa fa il
medico militare dopo la battaglia va sul
campo di battaglia a cercare le persone
che hanno bisogno di cure e decide in
quel momento fa una cosa che si chiama
triage in termine tecnico decide se val
la pena riportare questo ferito alla
base o meno alcuni feriti sono così
disperati che perdere tempo per salvarli
vorrebbe dire togliere tempo a qualcuno
che potrebbe essere salvato quindi loro
fanno questo lavoro inizia non
accogliere i feriti sistematicamente le
riportano nel campo base e che destino
può avere un soldato quando ritorna nel
campo base dall'armata napoleonica due
destini è un ufficiale e vanno il
quartiere degli ufficiali è un soldato e
va nel quartiere dei soldati
i medici francesi si accorsero di una
cosa gli ufficiali morivano come mosche
e i soldati sopravvivevano c'era
qualcosa nel quartiere dei soldati che
faceva la differenza
cos'era questa differenza che gli
ufficiali stavano al caldo ei soldati
sono al freddo non c'erano soldi per
scaldare i quartieri soldati che erano
soldati e quindi vivevano un po come
capitava
tanto è vero che amici francesi arrivano
addirittura in maniera un po gerarchica
a riscrivere alcune leggi su quando
giudicare una persona morta e tra il
serio e il faceto dicono se troviamo un
corpo in decomposizione quella è morto
d'accordo oppure se la sua testa è più
di mezzo metro al corpo anche in questo
caso andiamo per scontata e cerchiamo
che siamo negli altri casi valutiamo con
attenzione
e poi ci sono alcuni altri record
storici interessante questo la cittadina
di scop in russia una cittadina molto
povera nella nella sfera temporale che
ci interessa nella quale nel 1900 un
anonimo reporter potremmo dire per il
british medical journal i canali vista
medica prestigiosa
riporta che le persone di questo
villaggio durante l'inverno si trovavano
in una grande casa comune al centro del
villaggio è letteralmente l'inglese in
questo caso cattura veramente lo spirito
è quello che questo giornalista voleva
dire lui dice the walls liping the
winter of cioè si passavano via
l'inverno dormendo non stando insieme e
quindi al riparo dalle intemperie in
questa caso nama proprio dormendo per
l'inverno
nessuno mai certificato verificato
questa affermazione sta di fatto che è
compare nella letteratura medica
cosa ci può dire la medicina su questo
tipo di tematica beh questa è la
dottoressa anna bagel con è una collega
è una radiologa norvegese che un giorno
cade in un fiordo mentre faceva sci di
fondo e restò sott'acqua per circa
un'ora senza respirare ovviamente fu
recuperata con una temperatura col
poveri 13,8 gradi fu rianimata e la
dottoressa bene non sta bene e non ha
avuto conseguenze rilevanti sono
piccolissime cose da quell esperienza
non è l'unico caso non è un caso
miracoloso ci sono tutti gli anni in
caso due che vengono riportati di
persone che sopravvivono a
raffreddamenti che normalmente sarebbero
letali per quale motivo succede questo
non lo sappiamo però ci interessa sapere
che l'organismo umano può sopravvivere
tutto sommato in condizioni molto più
estreme di quello che noi sospettiamo
inizialmente dottoressa da cano una
lanka ha raccontato la sua storia
giornali medici piuttosto rilievo come
lancer per esempio e poi ci sono casi
ancora più interessante
questo è un paziente che si affaccia la
clinica neurologica dell'università di
bologna che fortunatamente la mia
università e con un disturbo molto
particolare chi è che arriva a un
dipartimento di neurologia di una grande
università normalmente persone con
malattie molto orale
ci sono più malattie del sistema nervoso
centrale che per tutto il resto del
corpo insieme ci sono malattie rarissime
diagnosi molto difficile da fare questa
persona frutta viva questa
sindrome lui sentiva stanchissimo la
mattina più o meno sempre la stessa ora
non riusciva a stare in piedi ma non
aveva sonno non era un sonno e
irresistibile era uno svuotamento di
energia riportava così
sta di fatto che tutte le sue esami
erano più o meno nella norma fin quando
un collega piuttosto acuto deciso di
monitorare tutto quello che poteva di
questa persona per una settimana e in
quella settimana scoprì che la
temperatura corporea di questa persona
qui in questi punti improvvisamente alla
mattina crollava e andava a una
temperatura molto più bassa
io ho fatto vedere questa registrazione
un mio collega tedesco che lavora da
tempo sugli animali che vanno in letargo
in ibernazione e mi disse questo è un
bel criceto solo che io lo fece un po
postamat ma questo è un criceto ma si
comporta esattamente come si
comporterebbe un criceto la parentesi
sappiate che molti proprietari di
criceti buttano via i criceti pensando
che siano morti invece sono
semplicemente in letargo e in
ibernazione questo è l'unico caso il
miglior caso documentato di torpore
organizzazione spontanea umana per cui
in qualche modo è un altro piccolo
esempio che ci dice che c'è qualcosa che
possiamo sfruttare la cosa vi era però
può più importante cosa ci dice la
scienza la scienza cosa ci dice ci dice
che intanto esistono diversi tipi di
ibernazione quello che appunto
volgarmente chiamo letargo loro sofà
un'ibernazione stagionale dura molti
mesi
il giro è in grado addirittura di
faraoni steve l'ibernazione estiva che
si chiami attivazione
quindi il freddo non è poi veramente
necessario vedremo che non è la
caratteristica chiave del ibernazione ci
sono animali che fanno un'ibernazione
breve che si chiama torpore che dura
mezza giornata un giorno qualche giorno
al massimo non un'intera stagione e ci
sono animali come lo scoiattolo artico
che riescono ad arrivare alla
temperatura corporea inferiore allo zero
a meno due gradi circa di varietà di di
possibilità che la natura ci offre tutte
ragione movimento però in qualche modo
collegate da dove viene questa
caratteristica sono animali più evolute
di noi non sono animali nuovi
sono i mali vecchie in realtà dobbiamo
partire dai rettili che sono i nostri
predecessori in questo caso un gruppo di
animali che non è in grado di regolare
la propria temperatura corporea e ha
bisogno dell'ambiente per regolarla
chiunque di voi abbia mai visto una
lucertola la mattina in montagna o in
campagna prima cosa questo animale fi
mettersi al sole per scaldarsi deve
scaldare i propri muscoli deve scaldare
il proprio cervello per poter agire nel
mondo che lo circonda con efficacia i
mammiferi noi facciamo un salto
evolutivo enorme e non abbiamo bisogno
di questo possiamo farlo senza perché
possiamo farlo senza il prodotto
mammifero il nostro antenato più lontana
non compare sulla terra 150 200 milioni
di anni fa
una vecchia storia compare in un pianeta
nel quale troviamo signori come questo
dinosauro e ovviamente non deve essere
facile immaginate per un animaletto più
o meno di queste dimensioni che deve
sfuggire alle predazioni dei sauri come
fare un modo e sfruttare questa nuova
potenzialità che mammiferi hanno
acquisito noi possiamo produrre il
nostro calore a noi non serve la luce
del sole
noi possiamo anche vivere di notte e
questo è quello che non mi faro fa
probabilmente all'inizio prodotto
mammifera notturno e vive quando i
rettili sono un po meno un po meno
attive un po meno furbi un po meno
svelte è molto più dispendioso però
viviamo per milioni di anni
su un confine energetico molto labile un
po ci stiamo un po no e allora per
risparmiare al massimo l'energia quello
che facciamo così tanto tempo fa è
quello di entrare in torpore e in
letargo durante il giorno cioè quando
dovremmo dormire in realtà proprio per
risparmiare il massimo che si può per
sopravvivere la notte e questo ci
avrebbe consentito di andare avanti ma
poi il destino ci è venuto in aiuto i
dinosauri si sono estinti
sappiamo tutti che sono estinti perché
un bondi è precipitato sulla terra
e a questo punto estinti dinosauri i
nostri mammiferi sono state in grado di
diventare finalmente diurni perché è più
economico vivere di giorno perché il
sole comunque aiuta a generare calore e
riprodusse sempre di più riprodursi
richiedeva di più era una strategia più
efficace rispetto
terminare risorse teheran e andare in
letargo quanto perché risorse ce n'erano
ovunque quando sono scomparsi in usare
questo il motivo per cui se noi
guardiamo tutti i mammiferi e guardiamo
tutti i gruppi di mammiferi marsupiali
carnivori primati pipistrelli e roditori
marchiamo con un colore ogni mammifero
che va in letargo fa torpore ibernazione
vedete che sono distribuiti a macchia di
leopardo
questo vuol dire che il nostro avo
comune che si trovava qui all'inizio
aveva un set di geni che ha tramandato e
che tutti i mammiferi e fra di loro e
condividono e che è quel set di geni che
ragionevolmente consente di sopravvivere
in questa condizione
quello che noi abbiamo perso insieme a
tutti gli altri nostri cugini è la
capacità di innescare e attivare questa
attività questa funzione del nostro
corpo che però è probabilmente ancora
presente nel nostro genoma che cos'è
effettivamente di cui parliamo questa è
una marmotta delle alpi è un animale che
i berna durante l'anno si fa lunghi per
nazioni in gruppo fra l'altro è con me
come l'ibernazione ora questo è un
grafico non spaventatevi fisiologia
l'avevano spesso in questa con queste
modalità vi spiego cosa guardare questa
curva nera è la temperatura della
marmotta questi sono i 37 gradi
tutti i mammiferi come noi hanno questa
temperatura corporea quando qui cade per
e teva 10 gradi questo è il periodo di
torpore la temperatura ambientale questa
qui è un po meno un po più chiara che
c'è sotto cecotto gravi quindi va quasi
la temperatura ambientale
ma questo non è l'evento principe
dell'ibernazione l'evento
dell'ibernazione quello che succede in
quest area grigia che qui quando la
temperatura è alta vedete è ampia e
improvvisamente crolla quasi a zero
prima che l'animale sia da freddy cos'è
questo questo è il consumo energetico
dell'animale il metabolismo deve animare
il grande azione è un'inibizione attiva
che l'organismo in grado di fare del
metabolismo che quindi causa
raffreddamento perfettamento è la
conseguenza e non la causa di questo
processo
e questo a molte applicazioni mediche in
teoria ci sono tante sindrome patologie
che possono sfruttare il freddo come
abbiamo visto già dai medici francesi
per migliorare molte situazioni cliniche
noi oggi non avremmo
un pò di affrontare questa parte clinica
però sappiate che questo è quello che ha
iniziato questo tipo di ricerche come
funziona cosa possiamo fare
immaginate di essere uno di questi due
modelli e il fotografo vi chiede di fare
questo questo servizio nella neve non
siete molto contenti loro visi sono
professionali quindi non tra sparisce
non traspare il dolore probabilità il
fastidio di questa condizione questo
perché il loro corpo sta difendendo le
dal freddo
il cuore il tessuto adiposo bruno i
muscoli la cute la pelle che quindi non
riceve più sano in questo momento stanno
tutti cercando di lavorare per
conservare la nuova energia e la loro
temperatura corporea
tutto questo ha controllato dal cervello
e il cervello che decide quanta energia
spendiamo e qual è la nostra temperatura
quindi come si fa a mandare in letargo
qualche anni qualche tipo di animale
qualche mammifero che normalmente non ci
va perché questa è la sfida l'uomo non è
un animale che va in letargo
bisogna colpire al cervello là dove
controlla queste funzioni e questa è una
piccola regione del cervello
questa è una ricostruzione
tridimensionale che si chiama raf e
pallido che è una specie di interruttore
che controlla quanto energia spendiamo o
quanto non espandiamo è una regione
molto antica dell'anci fra non sappiamo
ancora quali siano i suoi aspetti
evolutivi ma sono cose che andremo piano
piano a studiare cosa succede se noi
blocchiamo questa regione
succede questo questo è un roditore di
gross di medie dimensioni un ratto circa
4 500 g
in una immagine interroga [ __ ] più e
rosso più e caldo qui lo vedete in
condizioni normali
qui lo vedete in condizioni normali qui
non lo vedete più non perché sia
scomparso ma perché noi abbiamo con un
piccolo trucco bloccato quei neuroni che
controllavano la nostra spesa energetica
la nostra temperatura per aiutarli a
livello vederle ho disegnato io e si
trova qui ed è come la marmotta pochi
gradi al di sopra della temperatura
ambientale prima e così dopo così
immenso è in qualche modo di ibernazione
ma perché dovrebbe poi questo servirci
per lo spazio
beh la missione su marte che viene
costantemente rinviata prevederà questo
tipo di attività un fondamentalmente una
cabina telefonica volante che si
dirigerà verso marte con sei persone a
bordo e questa sei persone avevano
bisogno di cibo per un lungo periodo
otto mesi e mezzo ad andare otto mesi e
mezzo a tornare qualche mese per stare
su marte meno e spedire qualcosa in
orbita costa 50 60 mila dollari al chilo
quindi immaginate la quantità di costo
anche questa necessità provochi dopo che
ci sono altri problemi per andare su
marte nelle simulazioni a terra due
persone su cinque sviluppano uno strano
problema se siete mai stati in barca con
i vostri amici delle elementari pensando
di fare una bella vacanza e siete
partite in 10 siete tornati in cinque è
perché 5 di voi sono stati assassinati
nel sonno perché vivere insieme in
stretto contatto e senza privacy per
tanto tempo è molto difficile per noi
nelle simulazioni a terra due persone su
cinque sviluppano nata anche psicotico
che si chiama cabin fever nel quale
attaccano gli altri membri
dell'equipaggio e ovviamente se si farà
ci troviamo a metà strada fra la terra e
marte si chiama le carabiniere molto
difficile e poi c'è un altro problema e
le radiazioni i raggi di raggi cosmici
sono protoni quindi radiazioni ad
altissima energia che non colpiscono la
terra a causa del campo magnetico
terrestre ma nello spazio
diciamoci investirebbero in pieno
bombarde riavvio la nostra astronave
se andassimo in ibernazione cosa
succederebbe non avremo più bisogno di
cibo non ci potrebbero essere 20
psicotici perché al cervello nel letargo
si comportino in maniera
particolarissima molto interessante ma
che sicuramente non consente di
sviluppare un attacco psicotico e bonus
finale
questo ci darebbe uno scudo per le
radiazioni sono dati molto solidi che
mostrano che gli animali in letargo
hanno una resistenza delle radiazioni
incredibilmente più alta di noi cosa che
cerchiamo in questo momento di capire di
capire il meccanismo questo vale solo
per marte e vale soprattutto per la
missione successiva che sarà
ipoteticamente su europa che un
satellite di giove molto molto più
lontano di malta
tutto questo è bello affascinante e
forse verranno sviluppate nei prossimi
decenni ma è sempre utile e finisco con
questo parlare di quanto costa a fare
queste cose per cui brevemente vi faccio
vedere quanto costa un progetto
scientifico questo è il corso dello
human genome project che ha sequenziato
dna umano
questo è il corso di human brain project
un progetto della commissione europea
che cerca di ricostruire un pezzo del
cervello umano in un computer progetto
molto costoso
questo è il costo della lhc del cern
gradi bosone di higgs l'acceleratore
nucleare ne sono progetti molto grandi
molto importante qui fondamentalmente un
ristretto gruppo di scienziati alla
fortuna di lavorare questo è l'incasso
che ha fatto il film avatar
solo lui solo voi
questo è il costo del consumo di alcol
in un anno negli stati uniti e questo è
il costo della progettazione disegno dei
caccia f 35
allora è vero che la scienza costa però
è anche vero che bisogna mettere questo
costo in relazione con quelli che sono i
corsi con la società vuole affrontare
possiamo decidere di fare scienza di non
fare scienza la società è libera di
dirigersi anche in direzioni che non
siano scientifiche ma non possiamo
prenderci in giro dire che non ci sono i
soldi ma non c'è la volontà io non posso
che ringraziarvi di questa fantastica
giornata facendo rivedere ancora al sole
dell'estate il cielo da cui siamo
partiti anche perché questo cielo non
l'ha visto nessuno in quanto è
effettivamente una fotografia scattata
da marte qualcuno prima o poi la petraia
se guardiamo bene possiamo vedere la
terra e la luna che risplendono nella
lontananza del cielo io vi saluto ancora
davvero grazie alla canzone
[Musica]
[Applauso]